no es una decisión fácil de tomar en los
andenes de la estación del idif en el
oeste del país muchas familias y jóvenes
parejas esperan un tren para poder
volver a su hogar en ciudades como kiev
marina tiene 27 años y es de kiev cuyo
las primeras semanas de la guerra pero
atrás pasaron unos meses en libia
decidió volver a su casa para esta joven
no hay ningún lugar seguro en ucrania
así que prefiere estar cerca de su
familia
y
nos fuimos al y mi marido y yo porque
mis padres se quedaron en kiev estuvimos
allí unos dos meses en casa de un amigo
porque era muy difícil encontrar y
alquilar un apartamento así que hace un
mes el 31 de mayo volvimos y hoy sólo
fuimos salir por un día
su madre natalia tiene sentimientos
encontrados por la vuelta de su hija
por una parte me gustaría que ellos se
estuvieran lejos de la guerra pero por
otra parte los misiles vuelan por toda
ucrania y pueden ir a todos los sitios
jeff leaf o deza cerca de 30 mil
ucranianos cruzan la frontera para
volver a sus casas a pesar de la guerra
según la oficina fronteriza y lo hacen
en trenes como éste recorren cientos de
kilómetros con mucho miedo por los
bombardeos pero también con mucha
ilusión de poder volver a sus casas
elena estés en ccoo acaba de volver de
bélgica donde estaba su familia viaja
con su marido a kiev para poder recoger
ropa y visitar a familiares y amigos
vamos a estar en kiev unas dos o tres
semanas depende de la situación y
depende de cómo esté todo en kiev de los
ataques con misiles
y
el deseo de volver a recuperar sus vidas
hace que muchos ucranianos tomen el
camino de vuelta a su hogar